Prof: Okay.
Moving then as quickly as
possible into our subject matter
for today,
we begin a series of lectures
on various aspects of
twentieth-century formalism--
a big word.
At the end of our run through
the varieties of
twentieth-century formalism,
I hope it doesn't seem quite as
big and that its many meanings--
yet a finite number of
meanings--have been made clear
to you.
That is to say,
what we're taking up this week,
is as much really the history
of criticism as literary theory.
You remember in the first
lecture I said there's a
difference between the history
of criticism and theory of
literature,
one difference being that the
history of criticism has a great
deal to do with literary
evaluation: that is to say,
why do we care about literature
and how can we find means of
saying that it's good or not
good?
This is an aspect of thought
concerning literature that tends
to fall out of literary theory
but not out of the materials
that we are reading this week.
You can see that when Wimsatt
and Beardsley talk about the
"success"
of the poem,
they understand the whole
critical enterprise,
including its theoretical
underpinnings--
the question of what is a poem,
the question of how should we
best read it--
to be still geared toward
literary evaluation.
That makes the subject matter
that we'll be discussing this
week, as I say,
as much a part of the history
of criticism as it is of
literary theory.
We're going to be
reading it with a theoretical
spin.
That is to say,
we're going to focus on the
question of what a poem is and
the question,
"What criteria should we
invoke in order to read it for
the best and correctly?"
But there are other ways of
approaching this material.
In any case, then, Wimsatt.
Beardsley by the way was
actually a philosopher who
taught at Temple University,
a good friend of his.
In the book in which the essay
"The Intentional
Fallacy" appeared,
a book called The Verbal
Icon, Wimsatt collaborated
with Monroe Beardsley on three
essays,
and this is one of them.
So we try to remember to say
"Wimsatt and
Beardsley"
even though it is Wimsatt who
taught at Yale.
That in itself needn't be
significant except that the New
Critics,
the school of critics to which
he belonged,
have always been identified
with Yale and indeed
consolidated here a kind of
teaching method and attitude
toward literature which
constituted the first wave--
the first of two waves--of
involvement in literary theory
which amounts to the Yale
English and comparative
literature departments' claims
to fame.
Many of those figures who
belong to the New Critics did
much of their important work
before they arrived at Yale.
Others never were at Yale,
and yet at the same time it's a
movement closely associated with
this institution.
When I arrived at Yale,
Wimsatt was still teaching,
Cleanth Brooks was still
teaching, and so I feel a kind
of personal continuity with
these figures and understand,
as we all will more fully later
on,
the way in which the style,
and emphasis on the style,
of close reading that evolved
within the New Criticism
meaningfully and importantly
left its mark on much subsequent
criticism and theory that hasn't
in fact always acknowledged the
New Criticism perhaps to the
extent that it might have.
Much of this should be reserved
for next time when I talk about
Cleanth Brooks and return to the
whole subject of the New
Criticism and the way in which
it's viewed historically--
so much of it can be reserved
for next time.
But what I do want to say now
is this.
If it weren't for the New
Critics, none of you probably
would have been able to sit
patiently through any of your
middle or high school English
classes.
When Cleanth Brooks and Robert
Penn Warren published a book
called Understanding Poetry,
first published in 1939 and
then subsequently reissued again
and again and again as it swept
the country,
suddenly schoolteachers had a
way of keeping kids in the
classroom for fifty minutes.
Close reading,
the idea that you could take a
text and do things with it--
that the interpretation of a
text wasn't just a matter of
saying,
"Oh, yes,
it's about this and isn't it
beautiful?"--
reciting the text,
emoting over it,
enthusing about it,
and then looking around for
something else to say--
it was no longer a question of
doing that.
It was a question of
constructing an elaborate formal
edifice to which everybody could
contribute.
Students got excited about it.
They saw certain patterns or
certain ways of elaborating
patterns that the teachers were
talking about and,
lo and behold,
the fifty minutes was over and
everybody had had a pretty good
time.
This had never happened in an
English class before.
>
Seriously, you're English
majors because of the New
Criticism--I admit,
especially if you went to
private school.
This way of teaching did not
perhaps quite so much for a
variety of reasons permeate
public school literature
teaching,
but it was simply,
as a result of Understanding
Poetry,
the way to go.
It took time.
If you had more than
fifty minutes,
you could actually make ample
use of it.
T.S. Eliot,
who was in many ways associated
with the New Criticism,
one of its intellectual
forebears, nevertheless took a
somewhat dim view of it and
called it "lemon squeezer
criticism."
What this meant is it takes
time.
You've got to squeeze
absolutely everything out of it,
and so it was ideal from the
standpoint of teaching and was,
it seems to me,
also wonderfully galvanizing
intellectually because it really
did make people think:
"look how intricate what I
thought was simple turns out to
be."
The New Criticism,
incontestably and without
rival,
created an atmosphere in which
it was okay to notice that
things were a little more
difficult than they'd been
supposed to be.
This in itself was
extraordinarily useful and
constructive,
not just for subsequent
literary theory,
I think, but for the way in
which English teaching actually
can help people think better.
All of this the New Criticism
had a great deal to do with--
and when I talk next time about
the way in which it's been
vilified for the last
>
forty or fifty years,
naturally I will have this in
the back of my mind.
So in any case,
where did this preoccupation
with form--
because we're beginning to
think about the way in which
theory can preoccupy itself with
form--
where does it come from?
Well, needless to say,
I'm about to say it goes back
to the beginning.
When Plato writes his
Republic and devotes Book
Ten,
as I'm sure most of you know,
to an argument in effect
banishing the poets from the
ideal republic,
part of the argument is that
poets are terrible imitators.
They imitate reality as badly
as they possibly can.
They are three times removed
from the ideal forms of objects
in reality.
They're a hopeless mess.
They get everything wrong.
They think that a stick
refracted in the water is
therefore a crooked stick.
They are subject to every
conceivable kind of illusion,
not to be trusted,
and Socrates calls them liars.
Okay.
Now when Aristotle writes his
Poetics he does so--
and this is true and rewards
scrutiny if one thinks carefully
about the Poetics--
he does so very consciously
in refutation of Plato's
arguments in the Republic,
and perhaps the keystone of
this refutation is simply this:
Plato says poets imitate badly.
Aristotle says this is a
category mistake because poets
don't imitate reality.
Poets don't imitate,
says Aristotle,
things as they are.
They imitate things as they
should be.
In other words,
the business of poets is to
organize,
to bring form to bear,
on the messiness of reality
and,
in so doing,
to construct not an alternate
reality in the sense that it has
nothing to do with the real
world--
that is to say,
it doesn't mention anything in
the real world,
or it somehow or other invents
human beings made out of
chocolate or something like
that--
instead, it idealizes the
elements existing in the real
world such that its object is
something other than reality as
such.
This is really the origin of
formalism.
Aristotle is considered the
ancestor of the varying sorts of
thought about form,
and it's this move,
this move that he makes in the
Poetics,
that engenders this
possibility.
Now turning to your sheet,
in the early,
early modern period the poet
and courtier,
Sir Philip Sidney,
wrote an elegant,
really wonderfully written
defense of poetry,
in one edition called The
Apology for Poesie.
In this edition he,
while actually a fervent
admirer of Plato,
nevertheless develops this idea
of Aristotle with remarkable
rhetorical ingenuity and I think
very impressively lays out the
case that Aristotle first makes,
here in the first passage on
your sheet.
Sidney's talking about the
various kinds of discourse:
divinity,
hymnody, science,
philosophy, history--
in other words,
all the ways in which you can
contribute to human betterment
and human welfare.
He says in the case of all but
one of them, each discourse is a
"serving science."
That is to say,
it is subservient to the
natural world;
its importance is that it
refers to that world.
The first sentence of your
passage: "There is no art
but one delivered to mankind
that hath not the works of
nature for his principal
object."
This by the way-- although what
they serve is not exactly a work
of nature--
is why even that which is
incontestably better than
secular poetry,
in other words hymnody,
and also divine knowledge or
theology--
even these fields,
which are the supreme fields,
are also serving sciences.
They are subservient to an idea
that they have to express,
which is the idea of God,
right, and God is real.
There's no sense that we're
making God up in this kind of
discourse.
Sidney is a devoutly religious
person and there's no semblance
of doubt in his attitude,
and yet he is saying something
very special about the poet who
is somewhere in between divinity
and the other sorts of discourse
with which poetry is
traditionally in rivalry:
science,
philosophy and history.
And he says this is what's
unique about poetry.
Only the poet disdaining to be
tied to any such subjection
[subjection,
in other words,
to things as they are],
lifted up with the vigor of his
own invention,
doth grow in effect another
nature....
He nothing affirms and
therefore never lieth.
In other words, Plato is wrong.
The poet is not a liar because
he's not talking about anything
that's verifiable or
falsifiable.
He is simply talking about the
parameters of the world he has
brought into being.
Sidney thinks of it as a kind
of magic.
He invokes, for example,
the science of astrology.
The poet, he says,
ranges freely within the zodiac
of his own wit.
He also invokes the
pseudoscience of alchemy when he
says that the poet inhabits a
brazen world,
and of this--"brazen"
means brass--
of this brazen world,
he makes a golden world.
In other words,
poetry is transformational.
In representing not things as
they are but things as they
should be, it transforms
reality.
All right.
So this is an argument which in
outline,
once again, justifies the idea
of literature as form,
as that which brings form to
bear on the chaos and messiness
of the real.
Now I don't mean to say things
just stood still as Sidney said
they were until you get to Kant.
A great deal happens,
but one aspect of Kant's famous
"Copernican
revolution" in
the history of philosophy
is his ideas about
aesthetics and the beautiful and
about the special faculty that
he believes has to do with and
mediates our aesthetic
understanding of things,
a faculty which he calls
"the judgment";
so that in The Critique of
Judgment of 1790,
he outlines a philosophy of the
beautiful and of the means
whereby "the judgment"
makes judgments of the
beautiful.
He does a great deal else in
it, but I'm isolating this
strand, which is what's relevant
to what we're talking about.
In many ways Kant,
without knowing anything about
Sidney, nevertheless follows
from Sidney particularly in
this, as you'll see.
I'm going to look sort of with
some care at these passages so
all will become clear,
but particularly in this:
Sidney--and I didn't exactly
quote the passage in which
Sidney does this but I urged you
to believe that he does--
Sidney actually ranks poetry
somewhere between divinity and
the other sciences.
In other words,
poetry is not the supreme thing
that a person can do.
Sidney believed this so much in
fact that when he knew himself
to be dying,
having been mortally wounded in
a battle,
he ordered that all of his own
poems be burned.
From the standpoint of a devout
person, he had no doubt that
poetry was inferior to divinity.
Now in a way that's what Kant's
saying, too.
In the passages you'll read,
you'll see that the point is
not that art and the judgment of
the beautiful is the supreme
thing that humanity can be
engaged with.
The point is only that it has a
special characteristic that
nothing else has.
That's the point that this
whole tradition is trying to
make.
This is the way Kant puts it,
turning first to the second
passage:
The pleasant and the good both
have a reference to the faculty
of desire [The pleasant is the
way in which our appetency,
our sensuous faculty--which
Kant calls "the
understanding,"
by the way--
understands things.
Things are either pleasant or
unpleasant.
The good, on the contrary,
is the way in which our
cognitive and moral faculty--
which Kant calls "the
reason"--
understands things.
Things are either to be
approved of or not to be
approved of,
but in each case,
as Kant argues,
they have a reference to the
faculty of desire--
I want, I don't want,
I approve, I disapprove],
and they bring with them the
former [that is to say,
the pleasant],
a satisfaction pathologically
conditioned;
the latter a pure,
practical, purposeful
satisfaction which is determined
not merely by the representation
of the object [that is to say,
by the fact that the
represented object exists for
me,
right]
but also by the represented
connection of the subject with
the existence of the object [in
other words,
by the way in which I want it
or don't want it,
approve of it or don't approve
of it].
My subjective wishes,
in other words,
determine my attitude toward
it, whereas what Kant is saying
is that my attitude toward that
which simply stands before us as
what is neither pleasant nor
good,
but is rather something else,
doesn't exist for me.
It exists in and for itself.
The next passage:
"Taste is the faculty of
the judging of an object or a
method of representing it by an
entirely disinterested
satisfaction or
dissatisfaction."
In other words,
yeah, I still like it or don't
like it,
but my liking has nothing to do
either with desire or with
approval--
moral, political,
or however the case may be.
I just like it or I just don't
like it according to principles
that can be understood as
arising from the faculty of
judgment and not from the
faculty of the understanding,
which is appetitive,
and the faculty of reason,
which is moral.
So with that said,
perhaps just to add to that,
the fourth passage:
"Beauty is the form of the
purposiveness of an object so
far as it is perceived in it
without any representation of a
purpose."
You say, "Whoa,
what is this?"
>
Kant makes a distinction
between the purposive and the
purposeful.
What is the distinction?
The purposeful is the purpose
of the object in practical
terms.
What can it do?
What can it do for me?
How does it go to work in the
world?
What is its function among
other objects?
What bearing does it have
on--in particular--my life?
But the purposiveness of the
object is the way in which it is
sufficient unto itself.
It has its own purpose,
which is not a purpose that has
any bearing necessarily on
anything else.
It has, in other words,
an internal coherence.
It has a dynamism of parts that
is strictly with reference to
its own existence.
It is a form.
It is a form and that form,
because we can see it has
structure and because we can see
it has organization and
complexity, is purposive.
That is to say,
it manifests its
self-sufficiency.
So that's Kant's famous
distinction between the
purposive,
which is the organization of an
aesthetic object,
and the purposeful,
which is the organization of
any object insofar as it goes to
work in the world or for us.
An aesthetic object can
be purposeful;
that is to say we can view it
as purposeful.
I see a naked body,
which the art historians call a
nude.
Let's say I don't accept that
it's merely a nude.
I want it or I disapprove of it
and, lo and behold,
it's no longer aesthetic.
I'll come back to that in a
moment, but I hope you can see
that that is a distinction
between the purposive and the
purposeful.
Now just in order to reprise
these important distinctions,
I want to turn to a passage in
Samuel Coleridge who is,
at least on this occasion,
a disciple of Kant and is,
I think, usefully paraphrasing
the arguments of Kant that we
have just been engaged in.
This is the fifth passage on
your sheet:
The beautiful [says Coleridge]
is at once distinguished both
from the agreeable which is
beneath it [and notice the sort
of stationing of the beautiful
as Sidney stations it between
what's beneath it and what's
above it]--
from the agreeable which is
beneath it and from the good
which is above it,
for both these necessarily have
an interest attached to them.
Both act on the will and excite
a desire for the actual
existence of the image or idea
contemplated,
while the sense of beauty rests
gratified in the mere
contemplation or intuition
regardless whether it be a
fictitious Apollo or a real
Antinous.
In other words,
the judgment of beauty does not
depend on the existence of the
object for its satisfaction.
Now Oscar Wilde,
ever the wag and a person who
generated more good literary
theory in ways that didn't seem
like literary theory at all,
perhaps, in the entire history
of thinking about the subject,
says in the famous series of
aphorisms which constitute his
"Preface"
to The Picture of Dorian
Gray--
he concludes this series of
aphorisms by winking at us and
saying,
"All art is quite
useless."
I hope that after reading these
passages and enduring the
explication of them that you've
just heard you can immediately
see what Wilde means by saying
all art is quite useless.
He's appropriating a term of
opprobrium in the utilitarian
tradition--
oh, my goodness,
that something would be
useless,
right?–he's appropriating
a term of opprobrium and
pointing out that it is an
extraordinarily unique thing
about art that it's useless;
in other words,
that it appeals to no merely
appetitive or other form of
subjective interest.
We don't have to have an
"interest"
in it in the sense of owning
part of a company.
We don't have to have an
interest in it in order to
appreciate it.
In other words,
we can be objective about it.
We can distance ourselves from
our subjective wants and needs
and likes and dislikes,
and we can coexist with it in a
happy and constructive way that
is good for both of us,
because if we recognize that
there are things in the world
which have intrinsic value and
importance and what we call
beauty,
and yet are not the things that
we covet or wish to banish,
we recognize in ourselves the
capacity for disinterestedness.
We recognize in ourselves a
virtue which is considered to be
the cornerstone of many systems
of moral understanding.
To realize that we're not
interested in everything and
merely because we're interested
take a view of things,
but that there are things that
we don't have to have that kind
of interest in and can
nevertheless recognize as
self-sufficient and valuable,
is important.
Wilde's suggestion,
but I think also Kant's
suggestion before him,
is important for our
recognition of our own value.
By the same token,
all this harping on the
autonomy of art--
that is to say,
the self-sufficiency of art,
the way in which it's not
dependent on anything,
or as Sidney says,
the way in which it's not a
serving science existing merely
to represent things other than
itself,
right?--the way in which this
is possible for art is,
as also our own capacity to be
disinterested is,
a way of acknowledging that
freedom exists:
that I am free,
that things are free from my
instrumental interest in them,
so that in general what's
implicit in this view of art and
this view of human judgment,
and what makes it so important
in the history of thought,
is that once again--and this is
not the first time we've brought
this up in these lectures and
won't be the last--
it's a way of recognizing that
in addition to all the other
things that we are,
some of them wonderful,
we are also free.
There is in us at least an
element that is free,
independent,
serving nothing,
autonomous.
This idea of our freedom,
and by implication of the
freedom of other things,
from our instrumental interests
is what sustains the formalist
tradition,
and against various kinds of
criticism and objection that
we'll be taking up in turn as
the case arises,
sustains and keeps bringing
back into the history of thought
on these subjects the notion
that form simply for its own
sake--
as the notorious Aestheticism
movement at the end of the
nineteenth century put it--
is valuable.
All right.
Now John Crowe Ransom,
who was never at Yale but is
nevertheless one of the founders
or first members of a
self-identified school of
figures who called themselves
the New Critics,
published a book called The
New Criticism, and
that's >
where the term "the New
Critics"
comes from.
You may have noticed in your
Wimsatt essay that there is a
footnote to somebody named Joel
Spingarn who wrote an essay
called "The New
Criticism"
in 1924.
Not to worry.
That has nothing to do with the
New Criticism.
That just means criticism which
is recent,
>
a different matter altogether.
By the same token,
there is the work of Roland
Barthes and some of his
contemporaries--
Poulet, whom I mentioned,
Jean Starobinski and others--
that was called in the French
press La Nouvelle
Critique.
That, too then is an instance
of the New Criticism being used
as a term, but that too has
nothing to do with our subject.
The New Critics,
the American New Critics as
they are sometimes identified,
were a school--and I use that
term advisedly because they are
self-identified as a group--
a school of people who evolved
this idea of the independent
status--
Ransom calls it a
"discrete ontological
object"--
of the work of art and the
means whereby it can be
appreciated as independent in
all of its complexity.
Our first foray into the
thinking of this school will be
our reading of Wimsatt and
Beardsley's "The
Intentional
Fallacy,"
which I'll get to in a
minute;
but, simply as a reprise,
take a look at the two passages
from Ransom which complete
what's on your sheet and which,
I think you can see,
create a link between the sort
of thinking you've encountered
in reading "The Intentional
Fallacy" and the
tradition that I've been trying
to describe.
Passage seven ought to be
completely transparent to you
now because it is simply a
paraphrase of the passages I
have given you from Kant and
Coleridge: "The experience
[says Ransom]
called beauty is beyond the
powerful ethical will precisely
as it is beyond the animal
passion.
Indeed, these last two are
competitive and
coordinate."
In other words,
what they have in common with
each other, ethical will and
animal passion,
is that they're both grounded
in interest.
Right?
That's the point of Sir Kenneth
Clark's word,
"the nude."
<<pronounced
"nyewd">>
For the naked human being,
as viewed both by the appetites
and by moral reason,
as a common term from the
standpoint both of what Kant
calls "the
understanding"
and from what Kant calls
"the reason,"
the expression "naked
body" is just fine;
but if we do believe there is
another category,
the aesthetic,
viewed by an independent
faculty called "the
judgment,"
we need another word for what
we're looking at--
modern painters like Philip
Pearlstein and Lucian Freud
would strongly disagree,
but in a way that's the point.
When we're looking at a
painting of a naked body
we don't say,
"Oh, that's a naked
body."
We say, "That's a
nyewd," and that
distinction is what,
as it were, bears out the
implicit way,
the semiconscious way,
in which all of us acknowledge
there to be a category that we
call the aesthetic judgment.
On the other hand,
a lot of people think it's all
hokum,
and in fact the predominant
view in the twentieth century
has been that there's no such
thing as disinterestedness,
that whatever we are looking at
we have an interest in and form
views of,
and that this Kantian moment of
dispassionate or disinterested
contemplation is what the early
twentieth-century critic
I.A. Richards called a
"phantom aesthetic
state."
The predominant view is of this
kind of--but,
just to do it justice in
passing, there is a certain
sense, is there not?
in which we suddenly find
ourselves,
without meaning to and without
being simply victims of any sort
of cultural tyranny,
standing in front of something,
clasping our hands,
tilting our head and feeling
somehow or another different
from the way we feel when we
typically look at things.
And that, too,
is an intuitive way of saying,
"Yeah, however rigorously
we can define it or defend it,
something like this does seem
to go on in our minds at certain
kinds of moments of
experience."
We just feel differently
looking at a certain work of art
or a certain landscape,
let's say, than we feel looking
at other sorts of things.
Maybe we don't know why.
Maybe we doubt that the
difference is absolute in the
way that Kant wants to insist it
is.
Nevertheless,
we have in tendency feelings of
this kind and we should
acknowledge them because again,
at least in terms of a weak
understanding of these
positions,
it does tend to justify them.
At least it explains to us why
people can have had such
thoughts.
Okay.
Wimsatt--I keep saying Wimsatt.
Again it's Wimsatt and
Beardsley, but I already
explained how that is.
Wimsatt right off the bat
attacks what he calls "the
Romantic understanding of
literature."
Now what does he mean by
Romantic?
It's the attitude which
supposes that a
"poem,"
and that's Wimsatt's privileged
word which I'll try to explain,
that a poem is an
expression--
that is to say,
is the expression of some
passion or profound genius
working its way into a form,
but that the important thing is
the expression.
This much, by the way,
Wimsatt has in common with
Gadamer,
because Gadamer doesn't talk
much about authors either,
and Gadamer is interested in
what he calls meaning,
the subject matter,
die Sache.
Right?
He's not interested in
your sort of expression
of that meaning or my
expression of that meaning.
He's interested in the way in
which a reader can come to terms
with a meaning conveyed by a
text,
and that much,
as I say, despite the
profoundly different nature of
their projects,
Wimsatt and Gadamer have in
common.
So a poem is not an expression
but an independent object with a
self-contained meaning,
and if this meaning is not
self-evident to the attentive
reader then we don't judge the
poem a success.
This is where evaluation comes
in.
The success or failure of a
poem depends on the realization
of meaning.
It doesn't depend on our going
to the archive,
finding out what the author
said in his letters about it,
finding out what he told his
friends,
or what he told the newspapers.
It doesn't involve any of that.
If the meaning is not clear in
the poem, we judge the poem a
failure.
We don't refer--we have no
reason to refer,
if we respect the autonomy of
the poem as such,
we don't refer--we don't appeal
to an authorial intention.
Hence, on page 811,
the left-hand column,
about a third of the way down:
"…
[T]he design or intention of
the author is neither available
nor desirable as a standard for
judging the success of a work of
literary art…"
It follows from this that even
a short poem,
even a short lyric poem--and
here you could see
Wimsatt "following"
Foucault,
though obviously not following
but anticipating Foucault,
and again they have nothing to
do with each other,
but there is this overlap--even
a short poem doesn't really have
an author.
It has a "speaker,"
a figure speaking in the poem,
that needs to be understood
dramatically,
that is to say as though the
poem were one of Browning's or
T.S. Eliot's dramatic
monologues--in other words,
so that the speaker of any poem
on Wimsatt's view is a speaker
endowed with a certain
character,
a certain viewpoint,
a certain argument to be put
forward,
and our concern about the
speaker has to be a concern
within the poem about the way in
which this character is
elaborated,
and not reinforced,
somehow, by biographical
reference to that which is not
the speaker but the author
standing back there somewhere
behind the poem.
Now why focus on the
"poem"?
Notice that we never hear about
literature.
We never even hear about
"poetry."
The object of attention for an
analysis of this kind is the
poem.
Well, the poem is,
as John Donne puts it,
a little world made cunningly.
It's a microcosm.
It is a distillation or
quintessence.
It is a model in other words
for the way in which literature
can be understood as
world-making--
not a representation,
again, of things as they are
but of things as they should be;
whereby "things as they
should be"
is not necessarily an ideal but
rather that which is formal,
that which is organized,
and that which has a coherence
and makes sense
self-sufficiently and within
itself.
That's why the poem,
the lyric poem,
is privileged among the forms
of literary discourse in the New
Criticism.
All literature is by
implication a "poem,"
>
but the poem is the privileged
site of analysis whereby this
broader statement can be made to
seem reasonable,
hence the emphasis on the poem.
The absence of the Romantic
word "poetry"
is therefore not insignificant.
Poetry is that which just sort
of spills out of me.
It's the spontaneous overflow
of powerful feelings.
(Never mind that.)
The New Criticism isn't
interested in spontaneous
overflows of powerful feelings.
Wimsatt has his little joke
about drinking a pint of beer,
taking a walk.
So the New Criticism just isn't
interested in those sorts of
spontaneous overflow.
Sorry.
>
I won't go there.
But in any case, he goes on.
He goes on to say,
"All right.
If we're focused on the work of
art in and of itself,
on the poem,
we obviously in thinking about
what it means need to come to
terms with three kinds of
evidence."
That is to say,
some things have a bearing on
what it means and some things
don't.
What does have a bearing is
language--
that is to say,
words in the public domain
which all of us share and which
we can study in order to come to
terms with the exact meaning of
the poem.
A certain word--this is,
of course, what kept you in
your high school classes for so
long--a certain word has five or
six different meanings.
The New Criticism delights in
showing how all five or six of
those meanings do have some
bearing on the meaning of the
poem.
That's all legitimate evidence.
That is what one uses to build
up the structure of the
interpretation of the poem.
What is not relevant is what
I've mentioned already:
what the author said about the
poem in letters to friends,
to newspapers and so on.
That has no relevance.
Then Wimsatt acknowledges that
there's a sort of messy third
category of evidence which has
to do with language and is
therefore legitimate to a point,
but also has to do with the
author's idiosyncrasies--
that is to say,
the way that author in
particular used language,
certain coterie words,
or simply a private
misunderstanding of certain
words.
You've got to know when you're
reading Whitman what he means by
"camerado."
It's not exactly
>
what the rest of us typically
mean when we--well,
we don't use that word exactly,
but it's
>
what we typically mean when we
speak of comrades or
comradeship.
In other words,
the word is loaded in ways
that--
Wimsatt would probably
acknowledge--
need to be taken into account
if we're going to understand
what Whitman is up to.
Now this is very tricky,
and he spends the rest of his
essay talking about the murky
boundaries between types of
evidence,
type of evidence number two
which is out of play and type of
evidence number three which may
be in play but has to be dealt
with in a gingerly and careful
way.
But I'm more interested,
actually,
in a footnote which arises from
this argument about the
idiosyncratic nature of language
as a particular author may use
it because the footnote says,
you know what?
That's just one consideration
we bring to bear on the function
of language in a poem.
This footnote,
number eleven at the bottom of
page 814 over to 815,
is just about as devastating
and counterintuitive a
pronouncement as is made
anywhere in our entire syllabus,
the most earth-shattering
pronouncement that anybody could
ever possibly make in the New
Criticism.
Well, look at this footnote:
And the history of words
after a poem is written
may contribute meanings which if
relevant to the original pattern
should not be ruled out by a
scruple about intention.
That is bold.
The great creator raised his
plastic arm, right?
Everybody knows Akenside didn't
mean polymers,
but now we're all into
cyberborgs and we take all of
this very seriously.
In a way it's a tribute to the
great creator and also an
acknowledgement of the fact that
the great creator lives in the
Eternal Moment.
He's not subject to history.
The great creator knew in the
eighteenth century that some day
plastic would mean polymer,
right?
Obviously that's one of the
divine attributes.
Therefore, if the great creator
chooses to raise his prosthetic
limb,
that is simply a way of
understanding what it is like to
be everything,
omnipotent and omniscient in
the Eternal Moment.
In other words,
if you take Wimsatt's eleventh
footnote seriously,
that is a perfectly legitimate
way not to ironically undermine
Akenside's line but actually to
reinforce it and to give it a
kind of formal richness which it
does not otherwise have.
I realize that I'm out of time,
and so I'll begin the next
lecture by talking about a poem
of Yeats called "Lapis
Lazuli" written in 1935,
in which he talks about the way
in which people who build up
things that have been destroyed
are always "gay."
And of course,
if we invoke intention,
Yeats doesn't mean that they're
always gay in our sense.
He is using the English
translation of the German
word froehlich from
Nietzsche's The Gay Science.
Yeats is an astute and
careful reader of Nietzsche and
in some ways is elaborating on
what Nietzsche says in that book
in his poem "Lapis
Lazuli."
At the beginning of the next
lecture we will do the same
thing with the word
"gay"
that we've just done with the
word "plastic"
and then we will go ahead and
consider the essay of Cleanth
Brooks and other aspects of the
New Criticism.